I mean there's a lot of concern out
there right now that will see a
resumption of hostilities how concerned
about that are you I'm extraordinarily
concerned I think that the unfortunately
the ceasefire is very fragile there have
been incidents practically speaking on
average every single night of some sort
including the use of heavy artillery
from the side of the Russian sponsored
terrorists and that artillery should
have been moved back in accordance with
the with the Minsk agreements so I'm
very concerned I think Ukraine is born
an incredible burden in this war we've
had over six thousand deaths over 15,000
wounded with 1.1 million internally
displaced people this is one of the
largest humanitarian crisis in I think
European history since World War two and
how would a resumption of violence
affect Kiev's financial position well as
you probably are aware we've already
invested this year five percent of our
gdp in to our national security and law
enforcement so it's already a heavy
burden on the budget I would guess that
further destruction you know first and
foremost human human life is the most
sure it achill but the cost to the
economy continues we spend on average
five million dollars a day defending
ourselves from an unprovoked aggression
so the fourth quarter if I remember
correctly a contraction was close to
fifteen percent righton and then
industrial output contracted close to
twenty percent in January in February
what should we expect in terms of the
first quarter now that we're pretty
close to the end of it given the fact
that you know some of the hostilities we
have to cease fire now but continue
write it right into the first quarter
well I think this first quarter has been
very hard for us it's a quarter that
doesn't show any robust growth in that
region in particular yeah sure the
occupied territory of lu han's for
example i think the industrial
production dropped ninety percent ah so
that's influencing the entire economy of
course so what's quarter was fifteen
percent and that wasn't even including
the GDP yeah that wasn't even including
the separatist controlled area from Nam
taken right know that the occupied
territories are included in the
measurement because we're comparing
year-on-year and that falls out of the
measurement when you compare back to
2008 first quarter is going to be worse
than the fourth quarter why I think
it'll be around minus seven minus ten
percent overall for the economy but we
have a hard time even measuring frankly
speaking the occupied territories so
here it's hard to measure yeah and when
you talk about sort of we were talking
about debt restructuring I know you know
all you know an escalation of the
violence very difficult to calculate
what that would mean but could you could
you speak to what that would mean in
terms of creditors and what they could
expect if we get this resumption in
violence in terms of what your now your
needs might change well god forbid but I
think what it changes is the macro
economic forecast the basis upon which
the entire IMF program is built the IMF
program is built on a resumption of
growth in 2016 and no resumption in
violence and no resumption in violence
and so that is one of those external
shocks that I think all the creditors
and all of our international support all
of our international partners need to
take into account it's one of the things
we need to why we need to build this
cushion why we need to strongly move
forward in building this debt
sustainability because there are too
many external shocks out of our control
so when you talk to the creditors now
you explain to them that this is if
there is no resumption of violence and
if there is a resumption of violence do
you say it's you know I'll come back to
you with with suggesting more of a
haircut no no what I say is that they
need to understand how important it is
to accomplish this now to give us the
breathing space and to enable us to
return to growth given the potential for
all those external shots you've talked
about the need for more financial
assistance right you just got this 40
billion dollar package not buttoned up
right because you got the first trench
of the 17 and a half billion right how I
might billion dollars you've got the
five billion now and you're in the
process of getting bilateral aid
together how much more money does
Ukraine need now there's no magic number
I think this package but if you're gonna
ask for it you got to have a number no
no I don't and and I don't ask for
specific number
this package is enough i believe to
stabilize the financial and monetary
system the banking system which is
critical nothing can happen in the real
economy until we can stabilize the
currency in the banking system but above
and beyond that what we're looking for
is investment funds we're looking for
credits that our investment related not
fiscal not monetary and there is no
amount there what we can talk about
today is that we have sectoral
priorities meaning agriculture energy
energy efficiency infrastructure but
assume we have peace and if we have
peace we're going to need to rebuild
that disaster that you just showed of
destruction in the occupied territory of
that reconstruction know and that's why
when I go and I talked to our partners
peace will require a certain amount of
financial support as well you have any
idea what a you know a Marshall Plan as
people say like cost for Ukraine know
until right now I can't tell you what
the cost of the destruction is that
you've seen more of it than I have I
have estimates of the pipeline's that
have been bombed in the airports that
are missing in the infrastructure that's
been destroyed the apartment buildings
thousands of apartment buildings been
damaged but I don't have a good sense of
what the cost of restructured
reconstruction would be in terms of you
mentioned stabilizing the currency the
good evening you know it sort of was as
it as much as 40 to the dollar
thirty-five forty to the dollar it's
strengthened to around 22 to the dollar
right now but there's a lot of pressure
right there's a lot of capital controls
that are in place that are keeping the
good evening where it is how much
pressure how confident are you that that
22 is level is actually sustainable
where could we see a further weakening
and how far could it go given the
constraints right now keeping it where
it is including the what thirty percent
interest rates yeah I think that it's
not so much keeping the revenue and
control these administrative controls
that were implemented were really used
to try and eliminate the speculation the
fraud sure that was being used to take
capital out of the country in a very
volatile fashion I think where we are
now is closer to the fundamental value
and I would expect that assuming we can
continue to move down the road of
structural reforms that we've outlined
in the IMF program we should be able to
stay within this zone the IMF program
shows that you know assuming things go
well that we in the 22 to 24 over the
next four years as you're confident you
can stay between 22 and 24 that the hood
evening again for the next four years
I'm confident if we do what's necessary
to reform our economy that we can um in
terms of inflation twenty-seven percent
is where we are now do you see that
picking up no I think it goes down over
time and we're suffering right now from
the depreciation that's a huge part of
the inflation raising household tariffs
on gas which is an absolute necessity to
start removing the subsidies from our
state oil and gas monopoly enough to Gus
and instead provide them to the
population but that requires raising
prices eliminating the rent seeking
behavior that occurs when we have
multiple prices in the marketplace all
of that will have a short-term effect on
inflation but we should be able to come
back by 2016 to single digits when we
talk about financial aid and you're out
there asking for more money right now I
mean do you feel that Ukraine is because
of this geopolitical conflict playing
out on your soil better position to get
a then it might be otherwise I'd you
know I don't mean to be flippant but do
you feel that Western countries are
happy to give you money because of the
conflict that's going on in your country
and they just want to show solidarity
first of all I'd call it financial
support not aid because most of it is
credit right perfectly frank there is a
portion that's humanitarian aid which is
being given to to help us with the
humanitarian crisis but the bulk of this
is money we're borrowing and we repay
sure I don't think that anyone any
taxpayers give away their money or lend
their money easily so I think everyone
has a certain amount of conditionality
with regard to whether or not they want
to provide us support I think that from
Ukraine's perspective today more than
ever we deserve that support yes today
more than ever the Ukrainian people are
standing on the front lines defending
those values that the Western world that
the free world
as has abided by and live by and that
have inspired the free world for decades
if not centuries we're standing for
freedom of assembly freedom of speech
freedom of media sovereignty territorial
integrity this is what post-world war
two free world was built upon and so
today I think the Ukrainian people
deserve that support taken together with
the fact that they are themselves
reforming their own country and do you
feel that you know given the amount of
financial assistance or loans that say
Greece cot you know conversely the the
sort of opposite of what I was just
asking you feel like you're getting
short-changed that people have been you
know too reluctant to provide help I
would say that and we're grateful for
what we've received but this your
question I I would hope for more and I
think the Ukrainian people deserve more
I think that when you look at a Capitol
basis with Greece there is no comparison
the support for Ukraine has been much
much less yeah so I yeah I guess the
issue with gracious increases as part of
the eurozone and there was a concern
that grace might exit the eurozone and
you don't have that leverage do not that
leverage but we certainly are standing
on the on the border of a major
aggressor whose attack Europe coming up
now in terms of returning to the sort of
the future if we get a resumption in
violence ike i guess the government
forecasts you just mentioned it
somewhere between five and seven percent
for growth for a contraction excuse me
in 2015 if we get you know like people
say we could see the rebels go the
separatists going after medieval what
would that mean for your economy in 2015
I have confidence that Ukraine will
defend itself that are that our military
is more prepared today than it ever has
been that we have the support in
particular the UK for example with
military advisers with the US and other
countries providing us with some
training with some non-lethal support
but that's militarily my guess is that
militarily we are we will succeed in
holding them back ya dumb that comes at
a cost in terms obviously human lives
and first and foremost but but also in
terms of resources and potentially you
know not just a bad economic situation
there but throughout the country
well the rest of the country remember
this is seven percent of our territory
the rest of the country is operating
open for business in fact in some to
some extent attracting new investments i
SAT with investors last night for dinner
and many talked about investment into
the IT sector into agriculture today
we've recently had a sale of our 3g
licenses attracted three new licensees
for the 3g so it's not as if this war is
coloring the entire situation throughout
the country in fact the rest of the
country is very ready and very open for
investment I walked into a store on
March the eighth which as you know his
international women's day and I asked
what the most popular forgive me beer
was amongst the beers they had this was
outside of the separatist area inside if
you will Ukraine proper which is a bad
way of putting it but near the city of
Nippon Petrovsky a little village and
the woman looked at me and said deadpan
none of them are popular I'm not selling
anything she had just sold some
chocolate that day is this I mean can
you speak to me to the sort of chilling
effect this has had on the Ukrainian
economy this conflict give me at this
point I was a hundred miles outside
almost outside of the conflict zone it's
not just the conflict Ukraine is going
through a recession we're in the ninth
or tenth quarter of recession which
started post Lehman in fact in 2009 it's
23 years of incomplete reform 73 70
years of communism a regime the last
regime that left with a level of
corruption that was beyond anything we
had ever seen and having put 40 billion
dollars of new debt on the shoulders the
Ukrainian economy is suffering not
because of the war but on top of the
fact that there's a war consumer
purchasing power is down there's no
question but I don't believe they're not
selling beer she might not have sold any
that more men were making making lunch
for their lives of course they were of
course they would but I don't think it's
a question of not being able to sell
beer and and in terms of we've got a
story out today talking about the
oligarchs conflict that Ukraine faces is
something I wanted to ask you about
there is a Ukrainian billionaire by the
name of you go to color muy ski you're
obviously very well aware of who has
minority stake in several government
control companies also has a militia
that is helping fight the pro-russia
separatists in the east of the country
but recently he rocked up at someone
specifically state controlled enterprise
with some of his men with guns and we've
heard the ukrainian president talked
about the that you know we can't have
private armies and regional armies in
the country what do you think about mr.
Keller moyes keys actions over the last
week well I agree with the president
that there's no role for these private
armies the government has moved day by
day month by month to incorporate them
into the National Guard and that process
will continue until it's complete in
terms of what's happening in Kiev and I
haven't been there for a few days as
I've been on the road near sure editors
it's my understanding that today the
ministry of internal affairs it will be
ensuring that there are no private
guards nothing of any of any sort
remains in Kiev it remains it'll cut
enough that that the state company and
that law and order is first and foremost
probably because you're keen to get as a
shareholder in those companies the
majority shareholder II and obviously
some of the dividends that he's been
blocking so that to help replenish the
coffers yeah well in in general we're
taking on a huge state-owned enterprise
reform process which involves
transparent choice of CEOs access to the
financial records ensuring that
corruption is brought to an end in our
state owned enterprises and yes that
they provide some kind of fiscal support
taxes dividends they have a role to play
and then at the end also taking a look
at what we can privatize this year so
it's a much broader picture than just
mr. kolomoisky or just do could enough
you mentioned privatization mr. collum
oi ski raised the idea of nationalizing
some assets that were already privatized
any chance for that I don't think so I
think that's been a very bad thing in
the past and i think that the government
has no desire no intention to do that it
disrupts the market in a way that is not
does not create confidence and right now
our goal is to create confidence Natalie
you're Eska we wish you all of the best
in your pursuits thank you very much